[Music]
foreign
in the past decade no politician has
probably been more influential
in shifting china's climate policy than
xi jinhua
as china's lead negotiator at the united
nations climate change conferences
he's been critical to forging climate
agreements on the international stage
now he's a special adviser to china's
environmental ministry
and the head of a leading institute for
climate and sustainability research
a study done by that institute
contributed to china's decision to be
carbon neutral by 2060
so how is china going to achieve its
carbon neutrality goals in time
and what role will this climate veteran
continue to play
after working for china's environmental
protection ministry for almost a decade
shir was appointed as its head in 1993.
during cs tenor at the environmental
protection ministry
a management system for major air and
water pollutants were put in place
and in addition environmental targets
started to be included
in china's five-year plans these
blueprints for economic and social
development
which had previously been very focused
on economic growth
he resigned in 2005 after a series of
chemical plant explosions in china's
jilim province
the explosions were caused by the
improper storage of dangerous chemicals
and left six dead and dozens injured
a local river was also polluted by
leaked chemicals
and tens of thousands of residents had
to be evacuated his resignation came
as the environmental agency criticized
local officials for covering up the
accident
and for this blind pursuit of economic
development
which damaged china's environment but
the resignation appeared to be only a
blip in his career
and asia later assumed the role of vice
chairman of the national development
and reform commission at the time the
ndrc china's top
economic planner was responsible for
making environmental policy
social continued to have a leading role
in china's climate strategies
in 2007 shia was appointed as china's
lead climate negotiator at the un
climate change conferences by then four
decades of breakneck economic
growth had turned china into the world's
biggest carbon emitter
steadily though the country's stance has
shifted from defending its right to emit
to promoting low carbon development as a
national strategy
[Music]
[Music]
in china's policy making system it's
difficult to point to the role of the
individual person
but we know that sia played quite an
important role in proposing ambitious
climate targets for china
which were eventually adopted by the
country's top leaders
so the advantages that sia had is that
he is very well versed
in sort of the party structure and the
party priorities
as well as international climate
priorities so he knows how to translate
the international pressures into better
chinese policies
[Music]
[Applause]
is known as a very candid tough
negotiator
in international climate talks at the
durban talks in 2011
a video cia repeatedly banging a table
over what he believed
were hypocritical demands by developed
countries
was widely broadcast in china and yet
his counterparts continued to speak to a
sense of humor
and his general likability
foreign
beyond the negotiating table shia has a
personal commitment to fight for change
after traveling to parts of the world
affected by the climate crisis
so
[Music]
in 2017 received a 2.5 million
award for his efforts to tackle climate
change he donated the money to his alma
mater
chingua university hoping to encourage
the next generation of climate leaders
he's now the head of the university's
institute of climate change and
sustainable development
and his team's research has helped set
china's goal to become carbon neutral
by 2060. we are already seeing some
suggestions for how to make this happen
so one climate institute that works with
cs institute at xinhua
has laid out a plan of increasing
renewable and nuclear energy
and completely phasing out coal power
the plan entails a very gradual
transition over the next 15 years
with a rapid acceleration after 2035
so under this particular plan coal-fired
electricity would be eliminated by 2050
and china's energy mix would undergo a
dramatic transformation
we've also seen these estimates that
something like 15 trillion dollars will
need to be invested
over the next 30 years to meet these
targets
[Music]
since
[Music]
tensions between the u.s and china have
been rising in recent years
and the u.s government has withdrawn
from the paris agreement
but shir is convinced there's no time to
lose
bye
you